yeah welcome to this video playing swap
swap swap swap okay the coke on yeah
someone requested that I player a
classical line do I probably probably
have forgotten everything about that I
actually had something some things
prepared here they really have forgotten
what I did prepare I had some line which
involved long castles but was different
than the usual ones i don't really know
i have forgotten ok so my ideas he never
played bishop nitey for as you usually
do quick nightie for and g3 to prevent
this maneuver so i was i try to try to
play that here ok when to see three
hmm curious doesn't really seem like it
netted me much okay so g3 I just go back
to g6 and go for c5 shouldn't be too bad
and 95 actually have 95
hmm yeah uncomfortable cannot go 927 or
anything
yeah this is a very ugly very ugly he
just intends to play g3 and if I need to
take only five I'm in terrible shape
really am terrible Wow now Miss played
that really horribly
hmm
just awful okay i was i was really
fearing g3 I mean not that this is a
great or anything g3 looked absolutely
terrible I know this looks like Beck war
chest but Knight f6 will get me a temple
back I just I need to just need to
reposition my pieces and coordinate them
hmm I'm not sure about that one Knight
f6 woohoo give me a good good control
over the light squares maybe it's got d5
but I'm not sure should i go here yeah
why not okay and now let's try to
activate activate PCM takes Bishop takes
looks like interesting play was night f2
on various tactics
maybe I can even play Bishop deform the
show before would be good but ok
probably it will take on c5 no he didn't
ok so then I'll go here exchange his
best piece and weaken the dark squares
and the protest if he takes on default
place 95 got 90 to check so one
technical point yeah I think you should
have taken on c5 this now should be ok
for black maybe you should consider to
second your form not sure about that
maybe now there we go how to go about
this now
double like group d 6 maybe I'm rookie
658 I need to I need both rocks here if
you go see five miles a fruit d 5 yeah I
need both works I guess Proactive play
okay look d8i he's got this check coming
okay it's not not just the check okay
but I need to activate my books I don't
want to make a passive muth 26 King b18b
is also useful me and the nidus
instantly hanging if he goes night if I
of God rookie too okay taking c 5s
nonsense but just check Queen f5 or is
the better move Queen f5 not Queen at
five is good
so Roxy to probably and this I can just
take yeah this is good when goodness is
not enough winning okay but is this what
about this Oh q1 yeah okay come on I
need to a speed up
this is some at least I think a good
move maybe it's not the best one okay
this is a beta this is made check Brooke
do you want Luke Chang mid-white resides
yeah he outplayed me really in the
opening this right after the opening I
was in in terrible shape I really
thought this Bishop f4 would be a would
be a good a good maneuver here but
probably it's it's nothing of 95 95 as a
tricky move exchanging pieces black once
they exchanged a couple of pieces this
is help helpful this would have been
interesting and this now at least after
that leads to a huge trouble I have
really in bad shape here this this this
thing is basically trapped outside of
his own camp and it can only take and
taking is terrible I thought here just
just a queen f3 or something and I must
take now I have no alternative and move
it f7 is gone so I must take and then
all kinds of awful things and there even
any endgame is just terrible no but this
this was it still preserves the net sure
but it's a bit letting me off the hook
and this I think is already quite
respectable for black and the way he
played it I instantly got a good game
yeah I know I think he needs to take on
c5 the snow starts to get tricky
guarantee a black is like his better
check yeah no I'm just active it seems
that he cannot take on e6 the computer
gives a c6 CM check and after the
capture I'm really winning this this is
how much she cannot play this really big
chance off the check this line and after
this we need five if he goes here this
also check mate coming down day for
Europe do you want is not as also
winning okay it's the this I suspected
that this is also great yeah it also
wins okay the only thing you you
shouldn't do as a move like rookie to
intending Queen here because there are
checks and you lose the room alright
thanks for watching